je m'appelle david guez je mettais
toujours dit que j'étais destiné à de
grandes choses
ça n'avait pas marché comme prévu
jusqu'à ce que je rencontre mademoiselle
kelly campbell
tu fais quoi avec un million de dollars
monterey ma petite affaire je serai
chasseur de primes souhaite je te les
mettrai tous entendent hausser mon dieu
david chez moi voir la pression qu'a
balle est passée juste dans la raie des
fesses oui je crois qu'elle allonge et
l'arrêt qu'elle ne juge déflorer lee kun
hee lee m'a dit que vous bossiez
ensemble à la loomis
moi je dis que c'est une opportunité
incroyable
vous parlez de braquer une banque c'est
pas très difficile tu charges la
camionnette et tu mets les doigts
c'est aux réticences à la recherche de
cet homme déguisements que j'ai fabriqué
pour toi 16 dollar à 78 cents
je suis le fils de jésus et de catwoman
17 millions qui manquent
tiphaine je sais que vous êtes deux
hommes qui font un travail difficile
il est temps de dégager david gedge de
l'équipe pourquoi ça c'est moche
bon alors qu'ils vous voulez que je dise
oh pas maintenant pas croire c'est l'un
des deux dans vos chambres les garçons
tout à l'heure les enfants
400 et esprit français
battus 4 à clermont tu voulais dire quoi
tiens bien des niveaux
parfois il faut savoir tout ait
fonctionné
celle-là on l'a pas vu le dîner